en israël comme prévu l'armée a
entrepris de détruire complètement la
ville de yamit à trois jours de la
restitution du sinaï à l'egypte les
jeunes d'extrémistes de la ligue de
défense juive qui menaçait de se
suicider ont renoncé à leur projet
michels trudeau mission rafales tirées
en l'air le général erez commandant de
l'opération colombes rouge soutien
l'assaut ces soldats tentent de faire
descendre les derniers irréductibles des
toits des maisons où ils se sont
retranchés
ne lésinant pas sur les moyens des
lances incendies sont mis en action
projetant bague neige carbonique sur les
opposants comme sur les assaillants
cette bataille spectaculaire est
toutefois symbolique ces militants de
cinq mouvements d'extrême droite savent
qu'ils ne pourront tenir longtemps face
à l'armée baroud d'honneur pour montrer
leur attachement grand israël cherche
pourtant à monsieur begin sitôt évacuer
les maisons de yamit sont rasées au
bulldozer destruction également mais
d'un autre type à la périphérie de
beyrouth ont les raids de l'aviation
israélienne ont fait hier 25 morts et 60
blessés
un duel aérien a même opposé forces
israéliennes et syriennes
ce matin encore les fantômes ont survolé
la capitale libanaise et le sud du pays
ces attaques ont été condamnées par
washington paris et bien sûr par le
monde arabe
le bombardement de la population civile
raté les faits les deux
la lutte de d'amour est un acte
d'agression militaire qui n'est que le
prélude d'une agression plus labs qui
vise à l'occupation du sud liban et
tentative de pénétration dans la vallée
du but à